You probably didn't realize that you do these things in order to avoid being still
or avoid your problems
things like mindless scrolling
Compulsive shopping
emotional eating
substance abuse
or just trying to stay busy all the time
All of these things
are all strategies to avoid what's going on in our unconscious brain
things that we haven't dealt with
they're all strategies to avoid the unconscious things
that were afraid to process
but guess what
They don't go away
The unconscious stuff isn't going anywhere unless we pay attention to it
You really only have two options
option one let those strategies continue to run and ruin your life
or option two: start pausing instead of distracting yourself
start connecting to what you're trying to feel
start connecting with a discomfort that you're afraid to feel
You really have to change your subconscious programming
in order to see real self growth and improvement